hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so one of the
things that Aristotle is talking about
this contrast it's possible for any
burrs you or any advice to do the
actions that fit the category that fit
that matrix without actually having that
is a quality of your character so a
person who decides to go on diet can be
temperate you know for that week and
then they they laps back into eating
whatever they want or somebody who wants
to lower the amount that they drink you
know can do that sort of thing as well
but they don't actually stick to it so
they don't they don't actually have that
quality of character when you have to
force yourself to do things you probably
don't yet have that ball of your
character what it feels natural and easy
to you you probably do have that so the
same thing goes for justice and
injustice you can do adjusting actions
without actually being yeah they just
person if you keep on doing them you
will hopefully gradually become more and
more just personal become
who you are it's like any other sort of
discipline likewise if you do unjust
actions over and over again like taking
more than your fair share don't go a
point in time where you say yeah I
deserve that part you know and you start
to forget it was an unfair distribution
and your mindset will change and you
will have that that vice of injustice so
Aristotle says on you know we can have
various characteristics or kinds of
injustice and first in the extra talks
about our roles and this is kind of good
too thick he brings up 30 x 40 x up that
reason he has will turn brigand bullies
everyone so what's the difference
between a person who has stolen once and
a thief are they the same thing yeah
people the Jews eels things and
yeah and there could be some other
motivations like peer pressure and when
we say to somebody is a thief we're not
just saying well you get caught stealing
once were there for years that might be
illegal done but when we're talking
about character we're saying yeah this
is part of who you are that's the kind
of person I think also like a thief
thinks stealing these right to it they
consciously do so or like the things
that makes me conscious to do so where
is if somebody steals when they realize
it's wrong it's not necessarily
something that like they agree what they
wouldn't do it I think you have to do
anything yeah eventually the thief comes
to see that is this is what everybody
everyone is Yves I'm just the one who's
actually like being consistent following
through I bet you know here's another
one that we hit actually yeah person is
a bully right one thing to pick on
somebody wants or pick on people
occasionally or pick on people when they
pick on you it's another thing to like
go out and deliberately i'm going to
your the 144 this month you know and i
could make it life miserable right and
the bully often tells himself this is
this isn't okay what behaviors the way
to okay and bullying it before with
injustice brigand what he means by that
is what we think we would actually say
Robbie what's the difference in a thief
in a robbery thief just steals from you
know Robert beats you or much or uses
violence in subway
robbery is different than larceny petty
done right adulterer he talks about
adultery is being it was a major problem
back in Greek days people were screwing
around at each other and people were
seducing each other spouses that's been
going on all the way through history
every single society by the way people
find get some scruples about don't do
this sort of thing because it's
recognized that it's actually hard to
stay faithful to stay true and that that
requires work and that you know many
people are not going to do that now
what's the difference between somebody
cheats once somebody who you can count
on cheat it is cheating Jim once yes it
does make you an adulterer right but not
in the same sense as somebody who you
can count on when placed into situations
of temptation to too cheap and they may
exact see that is perfectly justified it
would be worse than like feeling remorse
about it what are other things we could
place in here roles that that would be
of that sort what are always people are
on I'm just see people that like yeah
you're right line and that's a good one
one you know telling one line does not
make you a dishonest person although
there could be maybe some circumstances
where everything kool les is down to one
moment if you tell that lie but that's
usually because it's going to lead to a
whole bunch of other lives isn't them
and a lot of times people ended up
becoming Liars by telling one lie and
then having to tell a whole bunch of
other lies to cover it off of it towards
the end you know they can't tell what's
real it's false but it's very different
to tell one lie then they actually
why to make that part of your character
so that's all sort of good warm-up or
aerosols with you here he says that what
really matters is the quality of the
action that we're looking at and so that
means it has to do with with the person
who's acting we want to ask a couple
questions they have knowledge of what's
going on I could you know if I throw
this chalk around this room I can be
reasonably sure that unless I like and
I'll throw it up there were over this
direction could hit somebody hurt them
right I'm just whipping truck around and
I'm probably gonna hit something I knew
I profess recent job at the jerk struck
hurts now what if I were like the
Wolfram torch on that thing up there
yeah the camera or whatever it is the
automates you know then the truck falls
down hits Rio and you're like knocking
luck it's what that was wrong with you
you know you're committing on justice i
said oh i didn't know i didn't intend
that at all I didn't think that was
going to happen you could say to me come
on she's right below this you where did
you think the chocolates going to go
what the hell's wrong right that would
be an example of what Arizona calls in
here something that you can proceed
you're not completely ignorant of them
but it's not done on analysis it's not
done out of being that person a very ill
will towards you or anything like that I
should have known better but like you
know most people and not that you know
prescient of everything and so I do
something dumb there's a lot of things
we do
right sometimes when students plagiarist
it's like that they don't actually know
at the time that the plagiarizing of
course that they were like to you know
you have crystal clear concentration and
think about everything that they've all
learned throughout you know their career
as a student they know that this
constitutes plagiarism but a lot of
times they don't actually write should
maybe say plagiarism going to lay down
the law it's going to go on here
transcript you know for every single
taste like that that's very different
than somebody who deliberately played
crisis isn't it we have this contrast
here so knowledge plays a role and there
could be what air assault is called
unforeseen you know miss chances I'm
throwing darts you know in a bar and
somebody is not pay attention they walk
across the path make it like that well I
didn't know they're going to walk across
the path right that's a Miss jeans
that's what he calls it up to here
literally the ad case of luck then
there's you know yours before
accountable for because if we actually
thought it through we would know better
but we didn't have you won 10 it wasn't
contrary to reasonable expectation if i
drive my car too fast particularly in
wet conditions like this may can get it
an accident right that's not an
unreasonable unfussy abort of thing i
can hurt somebody i can damage somebody
else's vehicles I could like end up on
the mayor's lon and have to tear
my counter out there you know all sorts
of bad things could happen but most
times when people get in car accidents
it's not because it said I'm going to
give it an accident today because that's
what I like to do and it's fun to hurt
other people and screw up property you
know if you have somebody who actually
like went on people's lawns routinely
and did donuts and tore them up that
would be a whole bit of em Mad wouldn't
that wouldn't be in error and Aristotle
says that when we do things knowingly
but not deliberately like when we write
the grip of a passion like anger then we
can actually start to commit we have the
other times we can circumvent unjust
actions we know what we're doing like
for instance um think about the things
that we say to each other when working
don't we say hurtful things you know
people get in arguments sometimes they
remember what they say something they
don't remember what they say when you
talk to them afterwards and your life so
did you really think that I'm as big of
a jerk as you made me out to be and
they're like no I didn't mean I just
said it at the time because you know
felt that way well it's still not just
act they're still doing something wrong
but it's not as if the wrong is inside
of them like an infection or eruptions
become part of who they are if they're
doing it out of malice from the viewing
it on vice
okay so that I'm the first there are
some people who actually are not just
right you can count on them to be greedy
to be stingy to run other people down to
take more than their fair share of
credit to damage other peoples goods and
not pay back there are people who are
like that right those people actually
take positive enjoyment and hurting
other people you know like the bully
first time the people that we pick out
is having these these negative things a
lot of times they have a vice within
within their personality or soul which
makes them just by the lake Aristotle
says who should you forgive you forgive
these you don't have to forgive these
you should hold people responsible now
it's very different to hold somebody
responsible for having done the feminist
yeah let's say somebody gets caught
stealing right stealing isn't unjust
after they've never stole it before you
might be tempted to say well we'll give
you a warning this time it was a matter
for discretion or something like that
but if they're doing it all the time you
say well you're incorrigible and you
need to be severely punished and the
punishment may not actually make you
knock it off but you know you need to
pay something that's an aerosol so
there's an entire spectrum here we
notice that this is a very important
part of virtue ethics there's a big
difference between simply of committing
an action and then actually having that
vice or virtue that's characteristic of
that can
action in here personnel there's a
dynamic interplay between two of them
how do we know what kind of actions fall
over here we look at the people who
actually are good examples of good
people we're bad people who have those
vices of virtue so with justice it's not
that hard to do because we're constantly
running into examples that where do we
often go wrong with this do you think
this sort of last plans he doesn't talk
too much does something good yeah maybe
if you don't forget people who just did
someone I just oh it was a one-time
occurrence one faith watch al hmm yeah
or were using so you think I know I was
kind of just related to like
distinguishing between the two it which
one which ones were which acts and
considered for somebody who have
knowledge about it or somebody to an
attendant like how do you go exactly
there are some problems you this is sort
of a rule of thumb kind of thing rather
than exact and then people can lie about
whether they knew or didn't know so then
you have to look over time see how they
behave that's why private records are
now the application of the law were
often inclined when somebody does
something that injures us or injure
somebody who we care about identify with
to not think that something like this or
even like this and to think they are a
bad person they must be punished they
must be no full full extensible law you
have to apply this in this case when
really it might be one of these cases
there are some things that make it
difficult to assess that you know if
you've only met the person once and they
screw you over you're probably an
attempted to place them in this category
right unless you're a very generous
person in which case you might be taken
advantage of because maybe they actually
are in this category and you treat it as
just something like this we also kind of
screw over other people as well if we
don't hold this is getting a little a
little bit complicated we screw over
third parties when we don't hold people
responsible for the reactions this is
why we have victims rights advocacy
because oftentimes victims get bad
treatment you say well the person didn't
really know what they're doing so just
forgive them just you know be okay with
it when maybe they actually did maybe
there are habitual offender you'll think
about adultery for example we if we tell
somebody probably only cheated once so
it's not a problem subject of temptation
you should just forgive them
don't don't you know hold of any sort of
function I am certainly not going to
punish them up they're coming into the
dinner party next weekend I hope you're
going to be there too maybe maybe we're
going too far and going up to the scale
that case so we can be too strict and we
can be too lenient you know I we apply
these categories but it's good to have
these categories doesn't it is that
useful to have distinctions like